the views and opinions expressed on this
program are those of the guests
appearing on the program and do not
necessarily reflect the views and
opinions of eight news now or next our
media group
there's no magic bullet you're not gonna
find some brand new tax that
that nobody um has ever heard of
tonight on politics now making the
budget work with the legislature just
days away
democratic state senator mo dennis tells
us where the money will come from
plus we need to have all branches of the
government
we shouldn't have one branch dictating
everything
having more say house senate minority
leader james settlemyer wants to give
the legislature more power over
pandemic-related decisions
and by december 31st
1.5 million claims were filed
[Music]
making dieter better recommendations
from the team
tasked with changing our unemployment
system
from eight news now this is politics now
thank you for joining us i'm john
langler the 2021 legislative session
starts on monday
it comes as the state grapples with a
pandemic massive budget shortfall and
sky
high unemployment while lawmakers their
staff and journalists will be in carson
city
the public can only take part virtually
you can only comment on zoom or other
online forms or through email for
example members of the public will not
be allowed into the capitol building
until
vaccines are given to the lawmakers and
staff
so what are the top priorities in this
session
several lawmakers say it's economic
development and education
last week we interviewed people from the
assembly the leadership
this week we're tackling the senate we
start with democrat mo dennis who is the
president pro temper
let's talk education um the the
funding formula obviously was a has been
a major
issue that you have been touting for for
a long time
what are the chances that that gets
fully implemented
during this session so i mean we're
going to look at that
um we're trying i'm trying to to
understand
what the governor's proposing in in his
proposal it's it's very important
for us to implement this new funding
formula it's transparent
makes it easy for everybody to
understand where the money is going
and it focuses education funding on
education
so i think we all have that goal to make
sure that that happens and that's what
we're working towards
but in in i guess in the hierarchy of
priorities specific to education
given the circumstances with the
pandemic just getting kids back in class
where does uh finishing the funding
formula
adjustments where does that fit on your
priority scale
well i think that's the number one thing
we need to do keep in mind the funding
formula is not
about how much money we're putting into
education it's how we allocate it
and having a transparent um funding
formula
that allows us to i mean even if we're
just looking at it we want to make
adjustments
it's very easy under the new formula to
make those adjustments
how much of a fight over money is there
going to be this legislative session
compared with the other ones it's always
a bit of a dog fight up there there's
not um
no endless supplies of funding to go
around but when you
when everyone gets together and you
start to talk um
how much of a scramble is it going to be
well i think everybody
is anticipating that you know we're not
going to have
any extra money and we've got what we
have and i think people are more
understanding as we get up there
i don't think there's a lot of proposals
i don't think people have a lot of
proposals that
that are going to require a lot of extra
money there are some other measures some
other
issues that you hope to tackle or uh put
your support behind
uh when the session starts
well definitely uh one of the things
that uh you know in addition to all the
issues that you know education
and the pandemic has pointed out in
education and in equities
i think economic development needs to be
another huge
issue that we that we need to tackle we
need to find ways to
expand you know the way that we
currently
bring in revenues for the state is very
limited
there's only certain ways you can do
that so the only way you're really going
to increase
revenues is to change our economy
in a way that we're bringing in
additional revenues from
you know we're so dependent on on
tourism
gaming and we've got to find other ways
to bring other
industries so that you know when we have
a pandemic like we do
right now tourism is the first thing to
go
and it's usually the last thing to come
back it seems though that nevada needs
some short-term
fixes is there anything short-term that
the legislature can do
besides wait for federal funding
as far as increasing right now any
short-term things would have to be
things like
making sure that we're that the internet
for example things that are purchased on
the internet that we're getting those
sales tax revenues
that's something that could be more
immediate um
you know any adjustments that we would
want to make um
to any of the existing taxes could bring
more that way
but you know this is a tough time to to
look at those issues and see what we can
do more
in the immediate so things like you know
trying to figure out ways that we can
save and maybe do things more
efficiently
now senator dennis of course was one of
the driving forces behind the change to
a weighted school funding formula here
in nevada that's where the money follows
the student
instead of being allocated to specific
schools
senate minority leader james settlemyer
also says
education is his number one priority he
wants to make students are back in class
first your thoughts on
how his proposal is going to play in the
legislature
when the rubber meets the road i feel
that since the party
in charge is also the party the good
governor i think that they will
go along with his budget and i think it
will say along pretty good
i think worry a little bit about the
concept is very optimistic
that we're only going to be two percent
down on revenue
uh i think as always it doesn't matter
what anyone says at this point in time
it really comes down to that final
economic forum number because that
establishes the amount of money that
we'll have
to spend how much unity you believe
there
can be on just a statewide level
between people who are maybe republican
and democrat and then also in the
legislative
session how much unity do you think
there can be
that achieved when you're up there
trying to get laws passed trying to
navigate the budget trying to work on
all these important issues
because i get the sense in your voice
that there's
there's frustration that still lingers
from what we've just been through
people are people they're great the
issue is sometimes that
parties choose to put certain
individuals forth in leadership
positions
that unfortunately sometimes can be
pathologically partisan
and that's the real problem we need to
do what's right for the state of nevada
and as far as the issue of what's
happened in previous sessions
yeah there's some bad blood things were
forced down the minority party
told you're just going to take it we
don't care about you
however if you look at the holistic
approach
95 percent of bills pass on a bipartisan
way what are some of the other main
issues that you would like to address
when you're in carson city at the
session
big topics there's a lot of things to
deal with we need to get the state back
up and running
education needs to be dealt with
we need the kids back in school
i know that sounds crazy but if you look
across the state we only have one county
that hasn't gone back to school
that's a problem and they're clamoring
that they need to get the shot
well teachers in northern nevada went
back to school without a shot
and so we need to figure out how to get
these kids back
in a productive environment when the
kids aren't in school
it makes it very difficult for the
parents
to go to work every day so to me that's
the main focus is the education
of the children of the state of nevada
and the way to do that is to get them
back into
the classrooms the other thing is i
believe we need some
guard rails on chapter 414 in nevada
revised statute that gives the governor
complete power to do this type of thing
without discussion with the legislature
we need to have all branches of the
government we shouldn't have one branch
dictating everything
it should have to go through the
legislature through the judicial
branches
in order to make sure that we have a
balanced form of government
the issue of changing the funding
formula
kind of got hesitated
a slowed down because of the pandemic
and a variety of other things
do you envision that being revisited and
what concerns do you still have
over changing how education is funded
and where the how the pocket of money is
dealt with
obviously the formula on the budget and
that one was not a republican versus a
democrat issue in any way shape or form
they did end up being a little bit of
north versus south uh
rural version and that's just a reality
due to mining funds and the way the
constitution was written do i imagine
we're going to have tweaks to it
absolutely every session we've tweaked
with the amount of money going to
education whether it be
rural whether it be urban whether it's
north versus south
doesn't matter we've always tweaked with
that formula to try to create a better
balance and we will continue to
we also spoke with senator settlemeyer
about how he thinks the
legislative session should run
essentially the way the state is being
run right now if businesses can have 25
capacity he believes the legislature
should have people
be able to testify in person as well
with that 25 percent capacity
you can watch the full interviews as
well as ones we've done earlier with
assembly speaker jason fryerson
and republican assembly deputy floor
leader tom roberts on 8newsnow.com
just look for politics under the news
tab
on tuesday the clark county commission
picks replacements for two open seats in
the legislature
they're both going to be democrats and
they have to of course live in the
districts they would represent
this week commissioners revealed who
applied for the assembly district 42
seat in spring valley that was left open
after alex asepha resigned
metro police recommended charges against
asepha in a campaign finance scandal but
those charges have not actually been
filed
six people applied for the seat they
include opportunity village executive
tracy marie brown may
and jack abasher iii he owns his company
owns several restaurants
and other commercial real estate in 2019
nevada became the first state with a
female majority legislature and now it
is becoming a female
dominated legislature about two-thirds
of the assembly are women while the
senate is split right down the middle
overall this year's legislature is more
than 60 percent
female coming up next on politics now
fixing unemployment
the legislature looking to make changes
at dieter we're going to take a look at
the recommendations from a task force
trying to get people paid and fight
fraud plus
nearly everyone agrees climate change is
a problem
i'm alexandra limon in washington with
some of the solutions congress is
proposing
your school or youth organization
welcome back
to politics now
[Music]
governor steve siselak wants to make
sure nevada gets its fair share of
federal grant dollars
he says the state is leaving millions of
dollars on the table every year
during a roundtable discussion local
non-profits said the biggest hurdle
was knowing what grants they're eligible
for and then applying for them correctly
governor sisolak wants to create a state
office to just do that this is a
change of perspective in terms of how we
do business this isn't a one-shot deal
to try to restore
some cuts that we've got coming up this
session and these are some cuts
if the 711 comes up with a bill that we
can change the infrastructure in the
foundation
to open up the spigot and get more money
coming on a long
term regular basis for you guys to put
out in the in the community that's what
we're looking to do
assembly woman danielle monroe moreno is
writing a bill to
create that office it would be a cabinet
level position answering to the governor
another plan is to create funding for
smaller non-profits to take
grant writing courses over at unlv
a task force looking into nevada's
unemployment system has finished its
work
it was a volunteer role for former
assembly speaker barbara buckley
this week she provided recommendations
for dieter moving forward while
addressing the current obstacles that it
still faces joe moeller looks at the
work that needs to be done
by december 31st 1.5
million claims were filed thursday deter
announced the rapid response strike
force leader barbara buckley will no
longer be helping the department
when the strikeforce began there were
245
765 claims in the backlog
thousands of claims still remain in the
backlog with the current processing rate
of 5 000 a week
the welfare staff can clear this
remainder by
february 7. thousands are still waiting
to have their appeals heard as well
something they say they are getting
through and adding 10 staff to help
next take the week of january 11th
723 appeals were reviewed
568 were either redetermined
and paid the appeal was withdrawn
or if it was or it was determined not to
be a valid appeal
leaving 155 to be scheduled
when the extension of benefits was added
many people were left without their
money
the department is working on what
extension comes first we are still
working out with the department of labor
what the sequence is
of how you get your p e u c
weeks and then go to state extended
benefit weeks
because we have to get the order right
dieter is updating computer programs
working on phone problems and
implementing new fraud fighting tools
the director says they know many are
falling victim to fraud especially with
the bank of america debit cards
she says every day they send claims to
the bank to be reinstated
but the bank is now behind we are
working on
resolving that and my understanding
right now is that bank of america does
have a backlog
in terms of unfreezing cards joe moeller
8 news now
several state lawmakers say modernizing
the computers and software at dieter
this session is a priority
right now there are four separate bill
draft requests addressing
unemployment in the system here in
nevada coming up next on politics now
will helping the climate hurt jobs
alexander limon will join us to break
down the executive orders
signed by the biden administration this
week
and can nevadans cash in on the lottery
we're going to lay out the long road it
would take to get powerball
and mega millions here in this
only on eight news now you're watching
politics now
energy secretary nominee jennifer
granholm says the administration the
biden administration
will focus on green jobs she also told
the senate energy and natural resources
committee that
she opposes using yucca mountain to
store nuclear waste
nevada senator catherine cortez masto
sits on that committee
granholm is the former governor of
michigan
the byte administration says it will
take decisive and immediate action to
combat climate change
the president announced several
executive orders to clean energy and
lower emissions
the byte administration's plan will also
focus on low-income communities across
the country
where high emissions increase asthma and
cancer rates
it creates both a white house
interagency task force
to address environmental justice as well
as an advisory council
it directs the department of health and
human services to create an office of
climate change and health equity
the biden team says it will offset job
losses in the oil and gas industry
by transitioning the workforce to the
clean energy sector
our washington dc correspondent
alexander limon joining us now to talk
about
uh the string of executive actions taken
by
president biden since he's taken office
let's start with
climate change several orders that deal
with the environment
although some of them have already
raised concerns including with members
of his own party
yeah president biden released this
massive climate change plan that
included signing those executive orders
and the plan does a lot of things for
example banning
oil and gas drilling and exploration on
federal lands it also creates an
inter-agency
task force to deal with climate change
and
actually a lot of new positions and
offices throughout the general
government
um to deal with climate change and
climate injustice so the vitam team also
really wants to focus
on helping low-income and minority
communities because a lot of times we
see
the worst pollution and impacts of
climate change
on those neighborhoods and it's very
hard for them to get out of that
but part of the problem is that this
entire climate change plan is going to
cost about two trillion dollars
this obviously coming at a time when
we're already spending so much money
dealing with the pandemic
um and then also there are concerns that
it could cost a lot of jobs in the oil
gas and auto industry
now the biden administration is trying
to push back on that thing we're already
paying a ton of money to deal with the
impacts of climate change for example
the raging wildfires that get worse and
worse
out west every year um and also the
hurricanes that get worse they say it
would actually cost
less money according to biden team to
deal with
trying to mitigate the impacts of
climate change another series of issues
are a couple of them actually the
president signed executive orders
dealing with
uh health care racial equality there's a
lot of them that he signed since he took
office
what are some of the other highlights
and uh how things move forward from here
so basically this was executive order
week every single day president biden
came out and signed executive orders on
one topic or another so
a racial equality that was one day and
he directed this was a big one he
dropped
the justice department to phase out and
end contracts with
private for-profit prisons because we
know that the prison system
and especially the for-profit prison
system negatively impacts
and disproportionately impacts
communities of color
um so that was one thing he also
directed the department of housing and
urban development to try to deal with
some of these historic and systemic
issues that we see that prevent black
and hispanic and other minority
communities from
buying their first home and you know and
president biden talked about you know
that prevents them from building equity
and ever being able to build
generational wealth like we see you know
white counterparts do
and that was alexander limon reporting
from washington dc
coming up next on politics now nevada
doesn't have a lottery
why is that we're going to explain the
long road that it would take to get one
here
paper towels from brawny you're watching
politics now
well there were long lines for powerball
and mega millions jackpots across the
country but
not here in nevada so why doesn't nevada
have
the lottery we certainly have plenty of
other gambling well it was actually
outlawed in the original nevada state
constitution passed in 1864
and since then plenty of bills to remove
that language have been written
but they've all died a very quick death
the closest attempt was in 2009
it was passed by the state assembly but
it failed in the senate
since it's in the constitution this kind
of measure would have to pass
both houses in carson city in two
consecutive sessions
and then get approved in a general
election ballot
it was done through an initiative
petition that would need to go on two
straight
general election ballots essentially
it's a long road
here's a look at what to watch as we
mentioned earlier the 2021 legislative
session starts in carson city on monday
there are new rules because of the
coronavirus people will have to give
their public comment on bills either
online or via a zoom link for now
those links will be on the nevada
legislature webpage
we at eight news now we're going to have
a crew in carson city for the beginning
of the session
two members of the legislature still
need to be chosen the clark county
commission votes on replacements for the
state senate district 10 seat
and assembly district 42 that selection
will be on tuesday
both of those seats will go to democrats
that'll do it for us this week here on
politics now thank you very much for
joining us
stay up with us stay up to date with us
on eightnewsnow.com
to check back with you later
[Music]
you